[Music]
when you go and buy a suit you're
usually going to get it tailored by this
tailor who's in the store and you're
going to tell them to like you know make
sure the waist fits and then you're
going to kind of walk out the door
chances are your suits going to end up
looking like this side of Tyler's suit
one side looks really cool this side
kind of looks like
well if I could go to this side I'm
going to tell you the three GQ secrets
telling your suit the modern way is to
make sure first of all that you take in
the sleeve most of the sleeves on suits
are made for football players they're
just a little bit too wide so you can
see on this side it's a little bit too
wide and you can see on this side that
that's come in a little bit so it's
narrow and tapered the second thing is
make sure that the sleeve is short
enough like you don't want a sleeve
that's long that's dipping into your
soup that's covering up your shirt cuff
makes the suit a lot more modern if it's
a little bit shorter and then let's go
down to the bottom of the pant you'll
see that this one is much more tapered
there's a cuff on it and it's much
narrower at the bottom you want to
definitely take in the leg give it a
nice cuff and make sure it's nice and
tapered and those are the 3gq style
secrets for tailoring your suit the
modern way